[Music]
corman
we just got here
have you seen
anything
like
ets
here or ufos
star people
[Music]
this place is alive guys ask her if
they're here if there are star people
here right now are there star people
here right now
there you go you got your answer
holy
carmen are you a star person
maybe it's because we're in the room
because you know they don't like men
she's just like look at it do you want
us to maybe do a little experiment and
step in another room while you take over
sure
did you not want to say anything else
because the boys were in here
[Music]
i think
[Music]
oh i get that a lot
um
[Music]
okay
she has trauma she does
okay
and that's why she doesn't like men okay
okay i respect that i respect that
totally
we're gonna stay over here and let you
have a conversation with demi
i have trauma too
so i feel you
and i get
it do you like to sing carmen
oh
you should sing something for her to me
no
why not maybe if you sang that sing a
song as an offering week we could come
back in the room oh yeah yeah
okay
if i sing you a song
can my friends come back in the room
[Music]
there you go there you go
cool
well i always think skyscraper when i
feel
sure singing something emotional for
people
[Applause]
[Music]
do you have to
make me feel like
there's nothing left of me
you can take
everything i have
you can break everything
i am like i'm made of glass
like i'm made of paper
go on and try to tear me down
i will be rising from the ground like a
skyscraper
that's the coolest standing ovation i've
ever
[Music]
you've had a lot of stuff i'm sure
you've probably never seen
anything like what's going to happen
happening right now not ever that's why
i'm so glad to be here man wow cool
you